I want to continue in Volume 6 and this will be the final segment of this session, November
17, 1904. How the soul can be food for Jesus. Having received communion, I was thinking
about the kindness of our Lord in giving Himself as food to such a poor creature as I am and
about how I could correspond to such a great favor. While I was thinking of this, blessed
Jesus told me, my daughter, just as I make myself food for the human creatures, so she
can make herself my food converting all of her interior into nourishment for me. In such
a way that her thoughts, her affections, her desires, her inclinations, her heartbeats,
her size, her love, everything, everything should tend towards me. And I am seeing the
true fruit of my food, because he feeds us so that we will be able to live in union with
him, which is to divinise the soul and convert everything within myself, would come to nourish
myself with the soul, that is with her thoughts, with her love and with all the rest. In this
way, the soul could say to me, just as you have reached the point of making yourself my
food and giving me everything, I too have made myself your food. There's nothing left
to give you because everything I am and everything I have is yours. Now we sing that to the Lord
and we make prayers of it, but the thing is it has got to become a reality, not just words,
that everything in us actually genuinely does belong to the Lord. So Louisa says, in the
meantime, I understood the enormous ingrastitute of human beings, because while Jesus danes to
reach such excessive love as to make himself our food, we then deny him his food and cause
him to remain on an empty stomach. November the 18th, 1904, this is a very important message.
The heaven of Jesus on earth is the souls that give a dwelling to his divinity. So what
makes Jesus happy and able to have a place to live on earth are souls who will live in
the divine will. As I was in my usual state, Louisa said, my adorable Jesus came for just
a little. And he told me, my daughter, when I come upon the earth, my heaven, when I came
on the earth in the incarnation, my heaven was my humanity. Now the humanity of Jesus
contained the divinity as well. So that's why it was his heaven. And just as the heaven
one can see the multitude of stars, the sun, the moon, the planets, the vastness, all placed
in good order. In the same way, my humanity, which was my heaven, it was the image of the
heavens that exists above us, in which everything is orderly. It was to make the order of the
divinity dwelling inside shine forth, that is, virtues, power, grace, wisdom, and the like.
So all the virtues are the stars and the planet is our interior given to the Lord. Now, when
the heaven of my humanity ascended into heaven after my resurrection, my heaven upon the
earth was to continue to exist, because after all he is risen from the dead. And it is the
souls who give a dwelling to my divinity. That's where he has his dwelling on earth.
That's one Corinthians 3 16. No, you're not that you are the temple of the living God
and that God dwells in you. Also Luke 17 21, dwelling in them, I form my heaven and from
them also, do I make the order of the virtues contained inside shine forth? So if the Lord
is dwelling within us, the heavenly virtues will shine forth from us as well. And you,
would you not want to be my heaven? Tell me you would, Jesus says. And Louisa says, Lord,
I want nothing but to be recognized in your blood, in your wounds, in your humanity, in
your virtues, in this alone, I would want to be recognized so as to be your heaven, but
to be recognized by all others. Jesus seemed to approve of my proposal and he disappeared.
So here, Jesus is saying that during the time of the incarnation, his humanity was the place
where God was able to dwell on the earth. In other words, he was the holy of holies.
And just like you see, great order in all of God's creation, the order of God's being
was shown in Jesus with all the virtues and the graces that were within him. And so he
wants to dwell in us in his divine will so that the same thing can happen in a smaller
measure. We're only tiny dots by comparison with him.
November the 24th, 1904. In order to give and to receive, it takes union of wills, naturally.
Being all afflicted and oppressed and seeing good Jesus dripping blood, I said, Blessed
Lord, what about me? Don't you want to give me at least one drop of blood as remedy for
all my evils. And he said to me, my daughter, in order to give, it takes the will of the
one who must give and the will of the one who must receive. In other words, for a gift
to pass from one to the other, there must be the willingness to give the gift and the
willingness to receive it. Otherwise, if someone wants to give and the other does not want
to receive, even though the first wants to give, he cannot give. Likewise, if the first
one does not want to give, the other can't receive. It takes the union of two wills.
How many times my grace is suffocated and my blood rejected and trampled upon. While he
was saying this, I saw all people swarming inside the blood of the sweet Jesus and many
would go out of it, not wanting to remain inside that blood in which all our goods and
any remedy for our evils are implosed. So all our redemption is contained in that blood.
If we go away from it, we're simply completely mad, crazy out of our minds.
November 29, 1904, this is also a VIP message. The divinity of Jesus in his humanity descended
into the deepest abyss of all human humiliations and divinized and sanctified all human acts.
This needs to be read ten times over and meditated on. This morning I was offering all the actions
of the humanity of our Lord, Louisa said, to repair so many of our human actions either
carelessly done without a supernatural purpose or sinful. In order to impotrate or intercede
that all creatures might do their actions with the intentions of the actions of blessed Jesus
and in union with them. The only intention he accepts from us is love. He did everything
for love. He is love incarnate. So Louisa was praying that all of us might do our actions
with the intentions of the actions of blessed Jesus and in union with them, and to fill
the void of glory that human creatures would give to God if they did so.
When I was doing this, he said, my adorable Jesus came. My daughter, he said, my divinity
in my humanity descended into the deepest abyss of all human humiliations. I don't think
we can understand. I don't think our minds can comprehend the depth of humiliation that
Jesus actually suffered and what it was for someone who was divine to take such humiliations
from his own creatures. I think it's beyond us to get that on board what we need to try.
So he said, my divinity in my humanity descended into the deepest abyss of all human humiliations,
so much so that there was no human act as lowly and little as it might be, which I did
not divinise and sanctify. That's why it is so important for us to give him every act,
every thought, every desire, every emotion, everything so that they will in fact be divinised.
This he said, in order to give back to man, doubled sovereignty, the one he lost in creation
and the one I acquired for him in redemption. And man always ungrateful and the enemy of
himself. We even say that ourselves, that such and such a person is his own worst enemy.
Man who's always ungrateful and enemy of himself loves to be a slave rather than a sovereign.
That's John 844, Jesus says that anyone who sins is a slave and that's just it.
So all the enormous freedom and glory that the Lord offered to us in creation,
and which of course was rejected in the fall, and we have to get back in redemption.
All of that is just set aside if we just choose to be enslaved to ourselves or to anything else.
By a means so easy, that is with the intentions of his actions to mine.
He could render his actions deserving of divine merit. Please underline that in green, white and
gold. All you have to do is align your intentions with his, your love with his, your experiences
with his. That's all you have to align it with his and offer it to the Father with his intentions,
to have everything completely divinized. With a means so easy, that is with the intentions of
his actions united to mine. He could render his actions deserving of divine merit, but he wastes
them and loses the device of king and sovereign over himself. Uses the privilege, we would say,
rather than device of being king and sovereign over himself. Having said this, he disappeared,
and Louisa said, I found myself back to myself. So December the third 1904, the so-called
mistakes that are in these writings, Louisa discusses it with Jesus. Continuing in my usual
state, Louisa said, I found myself outside of myself cast to the ground before the sun,
which of course is the divine will, whose rays penetrated through the hole of me inside and out,
leaving me as though enchanted. After much time, tired of that position, I began to crawl on the
ground, but I did not have the strength to get up and walk. Then after I struggled very much,
a virgin came who took me by the hand and led me inside a room on a bed in which there was the
baby Jesus placidly sleeping. Content for having found him, I placed myself near him,
but without waking him up. After some time, he woke up and he began to stroll on the bed,
and I, fearing that he might disappear, said pretty little one of my heart, you know that you are my
life, please do not leave me. He said, let us establish how many times I must come. And Louisa said,
my only good, what are you saying? Life is always necessary, therefore always, always.
In the meantime, two priests came and the baby withdrew into the arms of one of them,
commanding me to speak to the other. This one wanted an account of my writings
and was reviewing them one by one. Fearing, I said to him, who knows how many mistakes are in
there? And he with affable seriousness said, what mistakes? Against the Christian law? And Louisa
said, no, grammar mistakes. And he said, well, that doesn't matter. Only theological mistakes
would actually be something you'd have to be concerned about. So Louisa, gaining confidence,
added, I fear that it may all be an illusion. And he looking straight at me replied, do you think I
need to review your writings to know whether you are a deluded one or not? With two questions that I
will ask you, I will know whether it is God or the devil who operates in you. First, do you think
that you have deserved all the graces that God has given to you, or that they have been gift and
grace from God? Louisa said, everything by the grace of God. Second, do you think that of all the
graces that the Lord has given to you, your good will has anticipated grace, or that grace has
anticipated you? And Louisa said, certainly grace has always anticipated me. Well, then he said,
these answers make me understand that you are not deluded. And at that moment, Louisa came back
to ourselves. So this was the reassurance that Jesus gave to Louisa that her writings were fine.
Now, when you go to the higher volumes, Jesus will say that everything in these writings is from
himself. So December the 4th, 1904, it's easier to fight with God than with obedience. This is
Louisa's problem. As I was very agitated, Louisa said, and with the fear that blessed Jesus no longer
wanted me in this state, I felt an interior strength to go out of it. And this strength I felt within
me was so great that unable to contain as I kept repeating, I feel tired, I cannot take anymore.
And in my interior, I heard being said to me, I too feel tired, I can take no more. It's necessary
that you remain completely suspended from the state of victim for a few days. So as to let them
make the decision for wars. Now, the them here are the political powers that be who are in the
throes of making decisions about going to war. And then the voice said, I will make you fall
into this state again. Then when they do make the wars, we'll see what should be done with you.
And Louisa said, I didn't know what to do. Obedience didn't want it. And fighting with
obedience is the same as surmounting a mountain that fills the earth and touches the heavens and
without a path on which to walk. Therefore, it's insurmountable. I don't know whether this is
foolishness, but I believe that it's easier to fight with God than this terrible virtue, she says,
because Louisa is totally committed to obedience. And Jesus has told her that the same obedience
that was in his life is to be in hers. So she says, agitated as I was, I found myself outside of
myself in front of a crucifix. And I said, Lord, I can take no more. My nature has failed me.
I lacked the necessary strength to be able to continue in this state of victim. If you want me
to continue, you have to give me the strength. Otherwise, I quit. Now, she's as clear as daylight
with the Lord. And while I was saying this, a fountain of blood gushed out from that crucifix
towards heaven and falling back over the earth, it converted into fire. Several virgins were saying,
France, Italy, Austria, England, it's for them. And they were mentioning other nations. But I didn't
understand well. Most grave wars are prepared, civil and governmental. On hearing this, I became
all frightened, Louisa said, and I found myself inside of myself. I myself could not decide what
I should follow, whether the interior strength that pushed me to go out of this state of victim
or the strength of obedience that pushed me to stay. Both of them were strong and powerful
over my weak and poor being. So far, it seems that obedience prevails, though with difficulty,
and I don't know where I will end up. So here she has been given the great warning about the
first and second world wars. I'll give you Amos 3, 7. The Lord never does anything without telling
the prophets first. He always lets the ones who are close to him know what is coming,
and therefore they can pray and they can intercede and make reparation, and they can also warn the
rest of us. So notice that the countries in Europe that were going to be central to the first and
second world wars here. So the last text that I'm doing now, and then Volume 6 is complete,
is December the 6th, 1904, and it's about true death to self. The beginning of eternal beatitude
is to lose every taste for one's own. That's Matthew 5 verses 2 to 12. As I continued struggling,
Louisa said, "Blessed Jesus came for just a little, and I saw myself as naked stripped of everything.
Perhaps the soul more miserable than I cannot be found. So extreme is my misery. What a dismal
change. If the Lord does not make a new miracle of his omnipotence to make me rise again from this
state, I will certainly die of misery." Then blessed Jesus told me, "My daughter, courage,
the beginning of eternal beatitude is to lose every taste for one's own." Now, if you're to
choose God's will, you have to let go of your own will. If you have to choose God's ways,
you have to let go of your own ways. If you have to choose God's wisdom, you've got to let go of
your own wisdom, and that's what they mean by losing the taste of one's own. In fact, as the soul
keeps losing her own tastes, that's her ways of being and all the rest of it. The divine takes
possession of her, and the soul, having undone and lost herself, no longer recognizes herself,
she finds nothing else of her own, not even spiritual things. Now, there are people who are
prepared to sacrifice material things, not at all willing to sacrifice spiritual things.
And there are people who think they are holy, they think they're close to God, but they wouldn't
let go of their own opinion if you paid them. They wouldn't let go of things that they are
completely dogmatic about, but you find that as you travel from the beginning to the end of
the spiritual life, you've got to let go more and more and more and more. Let me give you an ordinary
example. I was told about a meeting that took place in a school in Ireland, and this school
took care of children from the beginning to the ending of school life, so primary and secretary
and kindergarten as well. And at one stage, the priests who were running this school decided that
they would put all the parents together at one meeting to talk about rearing children.
And the person who told me about it said she was utterly fascinated at what happened,
that the parents who had children under the age of two were completely dogmatic about how
children should be reared. And as you spoke to the parents with children who were five and seven
and nine and eleven and fifteen and so on, the higher you went in the child's age, the less
dogmatic the parents were. And the parents of teenagers had nothing whatsoever to say about
child rearing because everything they had ever believed had been challenged by their own children.
And so as they went along in their parenting, they discovered they had to let go and let go and let
go and learn completely new ways. It's exactly the same in the spiritual life. The people who are
completely dogmatic about how to get close to God and how to pray and all the rest of it are
at the beginning stages. The people who have most experience in the spiritual life are the silent
ones who don't preach and who listen. Why? Because they've been challenged in absolutely everything
they have ever believed. And they've had to let go, they've had to sacrifice, they've had to deny
themselves and very particularly opinions that they held on to very tightly they had to let go of.
So let's read this again now. My daughter, courage, the beginning of eternal beatitude or happiness
is to lose every taste of one's own that you've got to let go of everything. In fact,
as the soul keeps losing her own taste, the divine taste takes possession of her and the soul
having on dawn and lost herself no longer recognizes herself. She finds nothing else of her own,
not even in spiritual things. Seeing that the soul is nothing else of her own, God fills her with
all of himself and replenishes her with all of the divine happiness. So you let go of the human
happiness and the divine happiness moves in. You let go of the human satisfactions and the divine
moves in. You let go of the human will and the divine moves in. Only then can the soul be truly
called blessed because as long as she has something of her own, she could not be exempt from bitterness
and fears nor could God communicate his happiness to her. No soul that enters the port of eternal
beatitude can be exempted from this point. Please underline this in green, white and gold. This is
extremely important. I'm going to read it again. No soul that enters the port of eternal beatitude,
that means that enters heaven can be exempted from this point, painful, yes, but necessary.
Nor can she do without it. Generally they do it, that means they surrender, they let go at the point
of death and purgatory does the rest. That's really sad because it was not meant to be like that. Your
purgatory should be on earth and so when you come to the day of your death, everything has been
surrendered, everything has been given and so you go straight to heaven. Generally people only make
this surrender at the point of death and purgatory does the last job. This is why if creatures are
asked what God's taste is, what divine beatitude is, these are things unknown to them because they've
never tasted them. They couldn't articulate anything about it, but with the souls who are my beloved
since they have given themselves completely to me, I do not want their beatitude to have its
beginning up there in heaven, but to have its beginning down here on earth. When Jesus proclaimed
the beatitudes in Matthew 5, he intended that to be here on the earth and as our foretaste of glory.
I want to fill them not only with the happiness, with the glory of heaven, but I want to fill them
with the goods, with the sufferings, with the virtues that my humanity had on earth. Therefore,
I strip them not only of materials, tastes which the soul nourishes, considers as dawn, but also
of spiritual tastes we find not difficult to let go in order to fill them completely with my goods
and to give them the beginning of eternal beatitude. The Lord takes only what we can't take into
heaven with us and he gives us what we can only take into heaven with us. Therefore, not to allow
him to give us the only baggage that is allowed on our journey to heaven is utter and complete
foolishness. So at this stage I have completely recorded volume 6 because the rest of the text
is already recorded.